tú tienes el más poderoso aliado del
régimen sirio esta es la primera vez que
pisa moscú desde el año 2015 la visita
por cierto no estaba anunciada durante
su reunión con asad putin ha criticado a
las fuerzas extranjeras que están
combatiendo en siria sin mandato de la
onu una clara referencia a países como
eeuu o turquía durante la reunión que se
desarrolló en el kremlin putin apuntó
que las dos naciones rusia y siria están
cooperando con éxito contra la pandemia
de coronavirus de hecho damasco ya ha
recibido de moscú los primeros
suministros con las vacunas sputnik v y
sputnik light y por cierto está en
cuarentena y cuando fue esta reunión
entre ambos mandatarios también se
reunió con su homólogo sirio en moscú a
primera hora del lunes antes incluso de
que se valorase la posibilidad de
autoaislamiento de putin por los casos
de infección por con a virus que ha
habido en los últimos días en el entorno
del presidente